世の中に入っ
ものが阿部ありません
皆さん周りを見渡してみてください
ものがあります
そしてそのものは
ここに存在するということはそれは作った
誰かがいるんです
例えば今皆さんが座ってる創立
それも誰かが作ったから存在しています
それから皆さんが今着ている服ん
これも代払っん
それから関係
作り物の人もいいかもしれないん
サブではここにあると思います誰かと思う
これは4日僕が誰かもです
紹介しません
これあげたかったで僕がやって食った後メジロです
実際にボンゴワゴンを飛ばすことがあります
それからこれは皆さんご存知ん
がスターウォーズに出てくるアクセ
c い
今年かられませんね
ええええええ
そしてこれこれはこれもまた例が買ったり来てた王冠です
データカッターでも流行りだしてドンパートを組み立てていろんなで作りました
あぶればを染めないます
そしてこれこれは僕の顔を3 d スキャンしてそれを3 d プリンター
スプリントした僕の方の梅です
に出るジョンっ
当然れていればです
それから
それはー
ああああああ
ハーイはん
私は準備が
そしてこちらのハンバーこれは実は僕が着くと思います
rex 名古屋の上の方に字のベータもらえそのデータをもとにして木材
れたかった引き出し
看板を作りますん
か買った彼
泊2000円そして作るのにかかった時間
あった道時間ですしかも僕が1人減っていったじゃないんです
そしてこちら
これはですねー
確か皆さんの大きな拍手によって動くように作ったと思うんですが
今井ちょっと拍手をお願いしてもよろしいお願いします
これちょっと違いましたん
けどですねこれは
拍手の音で動くように出かけて
実は観客の皆さんに握手をしてもらうための
ませんはい
ご覧に僕は赤ちゃんの服ピーマン
これはもの生徒の網干ペースと呼ばれる施設があるおかげなんです
馬場氏 fest
レーザーカッターや3 d プリンターリスター発行さ機械が置いてある
ファブリックな工作スペースです
そこには色々な本が置いてあってさまざまな講座をすることがあります
このハムスペース者
学生からお年寄りまで様々な年齢のさまざまな経歴を持った性が集まって自由にモノを
生み出してい
このまでは左も誰もが平等です
ただモノを作る人でしかありません
例えば僕は学生ですがどこかの企業イン
社長が来たとしても同じものを作る人ですかいいん
この pams フェスで行われている工作は
デジタルファブリケーションと呼ばれていますその消したりファブリケーション特徴を
3つ紹介します
ん
属名
誰のものをしてい
デジタル工作機械を動かすためにはコンピューターで作ったデータを使って作ります
ゾーンを作ったデータをデジタル加工機に送信し
中にちょっと入れてあとはボタン押して
工作の加工が終わりの朝別
皆さんのうちに電子レンジがある思います
その電子レンジとほとんど同窓方法がありません
安全かつすっきれいに行います
そして特徴薄明
すぐに作れることです
実際工作機械はデータ通りに素早く正確に動いて
素材を加工してくれます
こちらの看板僕が目前でてきて
教えいただきと1週間初それがあったの1時間があります
そして3つ目
何度でも作れるんです
デジタル加工機械は米た際は同じられ全く同じ動きで全く同じものを何度でも好きな
だけ
作って
それから別山ファブリケーションに欠かせないならシェアの文化です
デジタル工作機械が登場したことによってものをデータによって作ることが可能になり
ました
世界中で多くの人々かそのデータをインターネットにアップロードし共有しています
あなたが何かを知ろうと思ったとき決して
必ずしもゼロから作りつではありません
ネットにアップされているデータを許される範囲で使ってものづくりをすることで
ございます
それから
ここにあるもの僕が作ったものです
なので作りカバー僕が知っています
その作り方をみなさんに教えることによって
ものづくりをすることができます
決してインターネットに限られ現実のし山仕方もあります
食べ
今バブル this あるかコッカーによって
小野ずクリア
よりデジタルそして
個人で様々なものが目指せるようになっています
おいそ10年前
マサチューセッツ工科大学の教授である
eu 半身編がこう言いました
今3 d プリンターが
くっているの獅子を押し出してい
モノを作っているは将来的には原子を押し出し
原子を好きなように並べることによって世の中のあらゆるものが作れるのだ
それはこのようなからすべてのものが目指せれません
そういうマシンから服も出てきますそれから椅子だってくれるんです
コーヒーわー
割烹と出てくるでしょ
そしてお金でさえも作れます
データされ
それからどのような工作機械何でも皆せる機会が将来的には誰誰もが持つ時代が来る
だろうと言われています
それは夢のような世界ですね
そんなことはありえないんじゃないか
思った人もいるかもしれません
しかし数十年前
多くの人はパーソナルコンピューターに対して同じことを言いました
ん
コンピューターもともとは巨大で簡単な計算ができるだけのものでした
しかしそれが戻っ大型化し安価になることによっていま
誰もが持つものになっています
そしてパーソナルコンピューターを使って皆さんコンテンツを作り動画を観たり音楽を
聴いたりすることができるなっています
だから世の中のすべてのものがみなせるマシーンが
どのように普及することがないとはいえません言い切れません
では
ものづくりというのがあっ
これから完全にデジタルになりそしてすべてが教えて完結してしまうのになってしまう
ん
人々が集まって工作機械を使う web スペースいう稚拙な買ってしまう
僕はそうではないと思います
世の中のすべてのものを生み出せるマシンみなせないものがあります
実は web スペースで生まれているのはものだけではありません
web スペースで生まれている者以外の者です
この岩重に生まれているものそれは
ラムボンドで貼ります
岩間が簡単に言うと
物置返してい
流れ誰か誰かのつながりです
それはあなたがこの誰かが作ったものを見たと言っ
こっそりと生まれています
これはまだ本当のつながりではないので文字通り
らそんな今後につながった関係でしかありません
ここで一つ僕のある今度に反する人とお話しましょう
このらがいつればもともとわからないのでした
僕はこれを光らせたいと思っていましたが技術と
応募がわからなかったんです
そこで以前 web スペースで電子工作をしている人が言ったことを思い出しました
僕はその人の拘束を見ているんです
次に幅スペースでその人に合った時にこう言ってみました
ん
これを時間したいんですけどできるでしょ
その後出来上がったのはこれです
つまり僕の間その電子工作が得意な人の技術が組み合わさってこの新しいものができた
んです
ゴンドア僕がその人の工作を興味を持って見ているとき
じゃあ発足生まれていたのがあるんです
がどんど
誰かの間誰か未熟とつなぐ存在です
ここで一つみなさんに聞きたい事があります
あなた僕の名前を覚えていますなっちゃう
パーフェクト見てはダメです
覚えてない人も多いと思います
でもソレハまた気にすることでありません
闇正解は良さ考えています
さて air
次の質問です
僕が作ったものは終わっているんです
まあ今見えてしまっていますがこのトークが終わった時に僕が何を作ったかみなさん
頭の片隅に残っているはずです
それがあります
気づかないうちに回っています
そしてそのなモンド実は個人の間だけで終わってしまうものもありません
大蛇山
そのものを作った人というのはその作り方を知っているということです
その作り方を共有することで誰かと誰かのラムーンは本当に協力して
ものを作り上げる
ちゃんとしたつながりになります
このようにしものを介して人がつながれ
これからもの販売かっ
を一度ん
普通のものを介さない
ちょっと人との関係を考えてみましょうん
裏こんな風にちょっと人とは直接結びあっている半径です
しかしこの半径の中に間に物が入ったときどうなるんでしょ
このつながりはより広がることになります
をはネットワークわー
ものを拝借1人道がつながっています
後には知識と技術が
あります
何でも乱されましん
この世の中に存在しているものしか見なせません
なぜならデータがないデータがあるものしか作れないです
では神新しいものを生み出そうと思っ
どうすればいいのでしょ
それは私たちが新しく作り上げるしかありません
その時に役立つのがが窪んだによるネットワークじゃないですよ
では最後に
今ここにいる皆さんの中にはものづくりにはまったく興味がない
たくさんいると思いますなので僕は皆さん
ものを作ること強制はしません
しかし皆さん今日僕が作ったものを見てしまいます
僕が1人これだけのものをつけたことを知ってしまいましたん
その事が頭の片隅に残っているはずです
もう僕の話を聞く前の世界には戻れます
あなたはいつかきっとものを作りたくなります
僕はあなたと一緒にこの世界にない新しいもの
皆さんに時が来ることを話になっています
ありがとうございました
はぁ